i can always tell how important someone
is but how many people are watching in
the zoom it's a lot
they're just making sure we're all
we're all
keeping to the scripts right
exactly
not to stray off the path um so i i'm so
curious when you were going into making
this movie
uh did you know like this might be the
last time or had you because i heard
rumblings that maybe you signed like a
contract extension and i'm sort of just
wondering i'm trying to dig
extensions every time they want me to do
a movie
like i designed a very short one at the
beginning so everything's
um constantly just like in a it's always
adjusting for me um
but uh
no i i i don't think of this either as
as the end yeah what i mean personally
you're one of the most popular
characters in the marvel universe i
don't see you going away you know what i
mean i don't know what capacity i'll be
back
it'll just be like
just like
if i don't know how to do it with that i
don't want spoilers anyway
um so i have to ask you like i said i
loved your look your performance in this
movie uh but my i did have a legit
question i think after watching it
because obviously i've seen the movie so
um like there's the big multiverse out
there did anyone ever explain to you why
you're not actually also searching for
vision in one of the other multiverses
no i've i
there are
um there's like a whole list of things
that um like my brother
my parents
um i think
uh
the
the main reason when we would talk about
um
you know if there is this multiverse
and in this in in the version of the of
the of the universe
this woman wasn't with vision
um
she
we that we liked having that be a
mystery but for some reason
he's not in her in her world and we
thought you know i always thought of her
as kind of more of a domestic wanda they
got divorced they're separated she's not
wearing a wedding band for a reason you
know like those kinds of things um
we liked the idea of her being on her
own but um
the idea really is that
the most important thing once you become
a mother in the world are your children
and that's why i was wondering someone
said to me maybe it was the darkhold you
know corrupting her making her just
laser focused on finding the kids
but the kids are part of her
myth as well
so i think that's also part of it but i
do think that once your mother
the loss of the of your child is more
painful than any other loss you could
ever experience so that's really why uh
i spoke to sam ramey and he mentioned to
me that he had a longer original cut
than you guys did a bunch of reshoots
and then you know the movie's like two
hours and five minutes so using my own
math i can tell there's a lot of stuff
that you guys shot that isn't in the
finished film and i'm curious if there
is one sequence or scene that you were
sad that you shot that isn't in the
final film
i haven't seen it
and i wasn't
shoes
so i ate yard on my reshoots
[Laughter]
it's it's so funny because i don't think
people realize like there's stuff in the
movie
that has
a number of people in a scene and like
none of them were acting together it's
all like people doing it on different
days
i
never met lots of people in the movie
do you think that would be the thing
that really surprises marvel fans the
most to learn about the making of these
films the fact that so much is done
without people in the same room i think
so i mean i mean also we're acting with
you know
ourselves as well so that you know
there's a lot of acting with um with an
imagination that we get to do
which is
a challenge and a joy um there's part of
it that that feels really imaginative
and childlike that we get to do
um
and also this this script was always um
a work of
a moving object it was never something
that was set in stone so i wasn't
surprised when they were doing the
reshoots but i knew that the reshoots
didn't affect my arc size um but when it
did affect me i just did voiceover work
for it
my last thing for you um years ago at
the age of ultron junket there's a great
viral clip going around i'm sure you've
seen it where you are talking about the
house of m like someone's asking you
what you'd like to see with wand in the
future you're like house of m but marvel
will never do it you know and and and
obviously
right like you know but so i guess i'm
curious since you are um you know you
can see the future um what are you
hoping that happens to wanda in the
future clearly you know what's gonna
happen
i don't know i know i'm teasing i'm
teasing
okay well what i i would someone just
said because you're bringing an x-men
wand is a part of the x-men franchise i
want to be there too and in my mind i'm
like yeah
i can't want to be with x-men too
so i don't really i have no idea i don't
know what i want but i know i want it to
to matter like i want there to be a
there's no reason to continue to tell
these stories unless they're really you
know strong good stories and that
they're adding something to the entirety
of the mcu and so um i i i will be there
if there's a great idea thank you so
much for your time i really appreciate
it wish you nothing but the best
you